speaking by the way of Donald Trump's
instability but also just more evidence
that Trump is genuinely not a good
person Donald Trump now is insulting
Republican senators based on how tall
they are Republican senator bob Corker
accurately accused Donald Trump of
running the white house like it's a
reality show that's really not
controversial right Trump's using
Twitter as a primary means of
communication he's firing people and
threatening publicly to fire people or
to force them out he's challenging
cabinet members to IQ test he's coming
up with nicknames for everybody that he
deals with it is a reality show but
Trump didn't like being called I guess
effectively a reality show president so
he called out Republican senator bob
Corker for his height okay bob Corker is
five seven Lindsey Graham by the way is
also five seven but apparently height is
only an issue when it comes to bob
corker and donald trump took to twitter
and said that the failing new york times
set little misspelled with a single
apostrophe after it why we don't know
and capitalized little bob Corker up by
recording his conversation was made to
sound a fool and that's what i'm dealing
with
Melania Trump supposedly is working on
stopping cyber bullying and meanwhile
Donald Trump is using social media to
bully people including fellow
Republicans now how do we know that
Trump was referring to bob Corker height
because bob Corker height has been a big
deal for Trump for a while Trump was
reportedly considering bob Corker for
Secretary of State but reportedly said
to his associates I can't give bob
Corker in the Secretary of State
position because he's too short to be
the top diplomat
so instead Trump hired Rex Tillerson who
apparently has a much lower IQ than
Trump choosing the guy that I guessed
Trump sees is not intelligent instead of
the guy that's 5-7 serious question why
does a guy who's so overweight as is
Donald Trump make some of make make fun
of someone who's short I don't support
making
fun of people who were fat and I don't
support of making fun of people who are
short but people don't have any control
over how tall they are and most people
at least to some degree do have some
control over their weight so why is the
guy in the glass house throwing stones I
really don't get it and it's just trumps
typical bullying it's funny because
Trump is a bully who still gets
ridiculed for every attempt to bully but
the guy is still a bully and this type
of behavior by being normalized sends
the message that it's okay for
politicians to behave this way
in other countries when they see Trump
make fun of senators for their height or
make fun of a journalist because of a
visible physical disability that they
have in other countries they're not
falling for it they see this and they
see it for what it is which is pathetic
and embarrassing but here in the US the
committee trumpets see this the ones
that don't say wait a second this has
gone too far
committed trumpets see this and it
actually to them legitimates this type
of behavior it legitimates the
anti-intellectual sort of playground
bully type behavior and it confirms to
them it's valid for presidents to behave
this way Democrats should be should be
able to completely destroy the current
Republican Party in the next two it
elections you're dealing with
chronically low approval ratings for
Trump including dropping approval among
Republicans as I told you yesterday Mike
Pence's recent NFL stunts at taxpayer
expense wasting taxpayer money Trump's
own Secretary of State calling the
president a [ __ ] wanting to push health
care bills that will take tens of
millions of people away from having
access to health care a tax reform
proposal that would be great for Trump's
rich cronies but not do much of anything
for the middle class if Democrats can't
capitalize on this in 2018 and 2020 it
is going to be their fault and I am very
concerned that Democrats are already
dropping the ball on the midterm send me
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show we'll be back with hatred mail
after the break today's program is made
possible by Wayne
dot-com I'm totally clueless when it
comes to wine but I do know what flavors
I like so I was able to go to try wink
dot-com / Pakman I filled out what they
call their palate profile quiz they
asked very simple questions like how do
you like your coffee
do you like raspberries or blueberries
and after answering these questions
wink will put together a few bottles of
wine that you should like based on your
taste preferences and they get delivered
right to your door as you drink the
wines and rate them on the wink system
where the wink system learns and will
continue to improve the selections that
you get from them there are no
membership fees you can skip any month
you can cancel anytime and wink has a
100% satisfaction guarantee so you will
never have to pay for a bottle that you
don't like and our viewers and listeners
can for a limited time get $20 off if
you go to try wink comm / Pakman now
that's try winc dot-com / Pakman which
is PA que ma n for $20 off that's try
wink comm / Pakman